[Music]
i have a vision it involves there not
being a new star wars property multiple
times each year and the product getting
diluted to the point of nothingness i
mean please keep doing it so i have
content to gripe about on here but i can
still be mad wet letters
jabba
just killed a man must you use your arms
full range of lateral motion while
running with a death stick down tight
corridors this is very dangerous so this
kid fell from a great height through the
roof of a spacecraft and not only
doesn't die but also does no damage to
the ship itself and we know there's no
damage because ghee's first question is
what are you and not holy [ __ ] those
repairs are going to be expensive people
who watch concerts with their arms
crossed the whole time yeah debbie i'm
talking about you debbie this uninspired
shuffle let's rock them rock em
rock em come on key you can do better
than that how about let's fire them up
or even flame on at least have your one
liner somewhat match the method of
weaponry you're displaying forced in
fiery crowd surfing wearing a cloak this
close to your rocket thrusters this is
the third time now that you've had your
concerts crashed by boba fett and you're
still performing concerts they're dying
for your art and then there's just being
a dumb ass not sure which this would
fall under but going to send it so i've
at least covered my bases cine rock'em
it'd just
be nice to finish a show for once does
this mean every time these kids play
they're interrupted somehow whether from
bounty hunters or weather issues or
venues double booking they've never
completed a show and they think they
have fans
clearly you're well past the we've been
followed stage less than captain obvious
i think you meant we've been hit i got a
bad feeling about this cliche i can't
just abandon him after all we've been
through at five minutes in we
confidently discover that the bounty
hunting failed music portion of the
episode has not in fact been a flashback
we've been in the present all along and
now we get our flashback to the
impactful moment when jay knew in his
heart that gee and he were meant to be
and you might think that we're about to
hit a little heart or substance that
will give this episode something with
more depth than the music anime trope
bathed in fan service but you're wrong
we're shown one simple handshake and i'm
almost sure that handshake was as limp
and lifeless as the plot of this episode
what are you except that is not how gee
said it before what are you and now i
know this show is trying to toy with my
emotions the first time we played
together i'm not sure whether i should
be impressed or concerned the first time
they played together their music sounded
the exact same as it does today jay is a
dick to womp rats and puddles just a
band i don't mean to discount the clouds
parting in the heavens shining down to
highlight the sincere connection the
band mates must have after practicing a
few songs and playing three shows but
wait no that's exactly what i'm doing
this is the dumbest i've ever seen under
the star wars banner all these people
are here for a pod race or an execution
both are a sin we made a deal with jabba
to let us perform before he executes you
oh yeah because cutting a deal with
jabba to perform like this would be a
really easy thing to do you know call
the jabba hotline and explain i've got
this banned thing and this whole
execution is a real bummer on our band
plans also maybe don't say executes you
so happily have you lost your minds you
don't need to get caught up in this yes
these dumbass kids lost their minds when
they decided to either exploit gee's
very public execution as a chance to
play to a big audience or somehow
convince jabba to let ghee go free after
hearing their horrible songs you're not
one to run away from your fans are you
who would use this argument to someone
who not only knows they don't have fans
but is about to be [ __ ] executed
[ __ ] kirty calm down it's just a mic
turns out it is just a mic and this is
the most anticlimactic experience of my
star wars life since my girlfriend
agreed to dress up as slave leia but
completely misunderstood the assignment
playing a guitar with a gloved hand what
sort of horrible person would invent a
device where the screen takes up such a
small space
dramatic cutaway to people in a bar
watching a live event cliche
the crowd calls for one more song and
they get the approval so when the song
is done is ghee going to be killed do
they have to keep playing to survive did
the writers work out their odd mixture
of star wars fandom and pin-up regret
about their failed garage band
when my hands on your grease gun that's
very subtle it's a metaphor
what are you it's jake from state farm
testing testing check check check one
check check sibilance civil stuff
come on
[Music]
who wants to play video games
you know what sucks
realizing that everything you believe in
is complete not a [ __ ]
do they rock or suck
they have not started playing yet